when I went to India the big question
they asked so they like in India they
they don't call you a teacher they call
you guru now for you know in my culture
when your guru you're like something
really it's like you're really special
you live on a top of a mountain and
stuff and so they didn't want me to talk
about all the stuff I did that I just
told you they they wanted me to explain
the sort of the religious truth about
Python and that was part of my religious
sort of awakening was I had to wonder
right because they said don't just tell
him about all your classes and all your
studio camera that they want to like
think of you as like the priests of
Python so so I had to think and I had to
understand why Python is such a movement
right so the first thing is is the core
of python is really tiny if I mean
literally I can teach I can get any
human on the planet Python in about ten
weeks and you've learned dictionaries
you've learned lists you learned files
you learned strings you learn variables
you learn loops and that's it and if you
think of what it takes to learn loops
and Java versus look learn loops and all
that stuff is so small the core of the
language is so tiny and the key thing
that python does that other languages
don't do is they don't extend the
language to achieve new things and
invade new spaces they simply build
libraries and so you can spend your
whole career a 25 year old Indian person
who just got a degree can literally work
for Accenture their whole career and
switch from web design to data mining to
online applications almost to mobile
applications and literally artificial
intelligence natural language you can
literally change any do any of those
things and never learn another string
variable right you're working with the
same string variable that you learned
when you were 16 years old and now
you're 35 and 45 years old and you're
looking at string variables so if you
start thinking about the SS insane it's
just so simple right and and one of the
things that you
if you've ever tried to write a see
extension for Java it is virtually
impossible it is like the hardest
computer science you'll ever do and
that's because the types are so complex
and then not only the types are so
complex and you have a bunch of like
methods that you've got to implement but
the types of the things coming in and
out of the methods themselves are
complex now this is why we love Java
because you it helps you not make
mistakes but it also means that it's
really hard to write C code and plug it
into Java and so the the primitives if
you compare Java JavaScript in Python
and PHP you just find that the
primitives in PHP are so beautifully
consistent and so simple and and they
get what you need done done and you can
extend it in other languages another
thing that I think is interesting about
Python is Python spent a decade going
from Python to to Python 3 and I think
that same decade that was Python was
transitioning from Python 2 and in his
sense fighting with itself I mean the
fight is over now Python 2 is going to
be deprecated like January 2 1 20 20 I
think but um vast majority of the energy
in the Python world was dedicated to
fighting amongst Python people as to
whether or not we should keep going
Python 2 because I don't want to port my
code that's that energy is now available
for everything else so what you're gonna
see is you're gonna see Python all the
brilliant people in Python have stopped
beating each other up and are moving
together now as one to do cool stuff and
all the libraries are there everything
that's necessary has been moved to
Python 3 there won't be a Python 4 I
mean it it took 15 years to design and
transition from Python 2 to Python 3 but
it is perhaps one of the most amazing
transition of a top 10 language in the
world from a major non upwards
compatible release where during the time
during the transition the
the nurse should just increased the
speed velocity increased so part of this
has to do for me with what life looks
like for a person graduating with a
computer science degree in 2015 and I'll
compare it to a person starting computer
science degree in 2000 in 1975 that'd be
me so these are just the languages that
I learned APL Fortran CDC sometimes it
was because I was teaching something new
sometimes it was because a new job at
times it was because I was learning
about web programming etc etc and so
these are all my jobs and all those
things now in this I've got languages
and then I've got kind of variations of
languages indented and in italic right
so you know I learned spring and I
remember you can kind of see the sakai
phase of my life starting here and then
I went back to teaching and then this is
my teaching phase in my life but here's
the thing someone this this the world
was trying to figure a bunch of things
out part and part of my problem was I'd
go from one operating system to another
in the 70s 80s and 90s right you can
kind of see where I found myself in in
Linux and UNIX at some point I was on
IBM mainframe for a while Rex I don't
know how many people here know what Rex
is and I was learning seashell so you I
mean it first part of that UNIX wasn't
even a thing right but then later UNIX
was a thing but today if you're starting
you're gonna learn some things like HTML
CSS JavaScript Python SQL and then
you're gonna spend a lot of your career
learning libraries of those things which
is not the same as learning a whole new
programming language because your string
function calls don't change you still
have dictionaries you still have arrays
you still have these primitives that are
the language right we're not talking
about capabilities we're talking about
the language and and then so this poor
person you know life would be good at
this point but then they got stuck in
some mobile company and now they had to
learn some stupid mobile code that's
like this isn't real Java this is like
Android job and then vb.net and then
they like you know I hate that and so
I'm going to learn
and then I learned all this stuff and so
this is later in their career and then
they finally actually have to learn some
see cuz I got into something super fast
and super performant
you know but what's the key thing is for
these folks it's all about libraries
it's not about languages right and here
these were I was if at some point I saw
variants like turbo Pascal but they
don't see that the future won't see that
they'll see libraries when new
capabilities are needed people will
build a Python library for that new
capability not invent a language right
the operating system is set the
languages for all intensive purposes are
set its about libraries going forward in
the future so this is just a summary and
I found this wonderful Wikipedia page at
least wonderful to me of all the ways
that you can do string functions in all
the libraries for the past 1 million
years including like if you're using
like you know rocks and breaking rocks
to do string searches and so this is
just like a you know APL Pascal C
JavaScript ASP right I put this up
because this is the crappiest part of my
life being on an airplane trying to
figure out if string X is inside of
string Y and where it is and what the
freaking return value is when I don't
find it is it negative one is it null is
there a try and except in the future new
programmers who only have two ways to
look for strings within other strings
there's the beautiful and elegant and
then there's the nasty imitation of Java
that is JavaScript right and I'm just
telling you this weighs a ton of my time
the more languages you have in your head
the more time you waste trying to figure
out whether the word world
is inside of hello world or not this is
a great website on you know how much
time I got left how much time do I got
nine fifteen or nine thirty got twenty
minutes okay so we get bored take a look
at this this is TOB and it's it's great
view of like the most popular
programming languages and this is sort
of like the current ones and the key
thing is there's a ton of them
but the thing I'd call your attention to
if you take a look at this is the
languages that are going down and in a
sense why the languages they're going
down or going down so we got Ruby going
down
we got peach pea going down we got Ruby
go down if you look down a little
further you see are going down now I
basically say that the reason Ruby is
going down it's probably cuz Ruby sucks
and that's why it's got two downs but
Ruby's going down but what is the thing
that's taking over from Ruby what is the
thing that's like rip and Ruby off we're
taking the Ruby programmers and say come
to me come to me
well it's Python but then down here is
our sink and fast to where the are
people going come to Python come to
Python right where the PHP people going
come to Python come to Python right so
what you often saw was you saw fights
between things like you know Objective C
and C++ right okay well you see now one
language that's crossing application
spaces and began destroying taking away
talent from those other spaces across
many spaces and that goes back to that
picture of you learn Python and you keep
going right
you don't learn a new string function
set but you have a career that evolves
and grows and does a ton of fun things
that are completely different for your
old career this is the historical one
right so Python sort of starts low you
know and these are just some of the
other ones right this is a historical so
this is a fun thing to look at and then
try to try to understand why that's not
number one yet and we of course are Java
I was talking in this morning we started
out the many of us in ninth in 2001
maybe 2002 and JE a sig which I was
talking to Ian that Jay a sig and a
pareo are surprisingly connected because
of the t-shirt that you're wearing the
reason we're in this room is not to
build a better learning management
system than canvas even though that's a
fun hobby to have
the reason we're in the room is we're
academics and we want to do something
that's not just been handed to us we
need to band together and that was no
different in 2001 than it is today in
2019 we are academics who don't want to
accept the status quo and want to take
matters into our own hands and we use
open sort open sources not the end as
the means to the end the end is us being
together and saying what are you doing
at your University and open sources the
way that we can get the stuff out of our
universities and past the tech transfer
at the University and into other
universities so open source is not why
we're here
we're here because of the people and
that's what I want to promote as I go
around the world talking to people about
a pareo outside of our community as this
is the place that University Tech people
who are not satisfied with the status
quo should come how much time I got
ok so one of the things that I'm doing
in this talk is I'm making a statement
as if I believed it to be true and I
sort of mostly believe it to be true but
I want to challenge you to disagree with
me and so sometimes I'll say what
questions and then people throw our
hands up and they start asking me
questions and I'll just some of the
times I've given this before the common
question is what about JavaScript right
there's a bunch of JavaScript people and
I want to show you a little tiny video
that I use when I start teaching
JavaScript I've taught JavaScript to a
bunch of people and I'm going to show
you a little tiny video from a fella
named Gary Bernard and he is a thinker
he's like a fun keynote speaker about
like the future of stuff right so he's
mostly seized the world through humor
and and so this is a slight new talk he
gave I'm going to start in the middle
called watt and he's just talking about
like the funkiness of JavaScript and
then I'll talk about the actual serious
part about it so let me get this up
let's talk about JavaScript does anyone
know in JavaScript what array plus array
well let me ask you this first
what should array plus array be empty
array I would also except type error
that is not whatever a plus array is
wrong wrong a rapist array is empty
string obviously I think that's the
thing that's obvious to everyone now
what a what would array plus object be
this should obviously be type error
because those are completely disparate
types does anyone know what this is no
clothes no far away it's object
basically done now of course because
this is plus so you can flip the
operands and the same thing comes out so
if we do what no that's just an object
if you do object plus arrays you get
exactly the same thing which as you can
see you do and finally the only one of
these it's actually true is because you
know you add a raising an empty string
that doesn't make sense but an object
plus an object is actually not a number
technically
so this one's actually right and exactly
right like what is even going on in this
lat I just I don't even understand what
person with a brain in their head would
think that any of this is a good idea
okay okay enough making fun of languages
it sucked
let's talk about JavaScript if I say a
ray dot new 16 or just array 16 I get an
array of 16 things which it represents
as 16 commas which is obvious and if I
then join those with a string then I get
this string 16 times this is actually
the only line in this entire
presentation that's reasonable now if I
take that string and then add a 1 to it
it interprets the 1 is cast for 1/2 a
string and then we get 1 bunch of times
fine does anyone know what will happen
if I subtract 1 from this I'm assuming
no one does let me I'll give you a hint
does does this help does anyone know
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's all I got thank you
so I I am just showing you that as an ad
to watch this other talk that I
reference here and that says his birth
and death of JavaScript which is
actually a 35-minute serious talk in why
why what he's really telling you is that
the core fundamental consistency of a
language actually kind of matters and
there's a lot of sloppiness in
JavaScript but I encourage you to watch
the birth and death of JavaScript and
the short version of the birth and death
of JavaScript is that javascript is not
the general-purpose language of the
future
javascript is actually the machine
language of the future it is the
operating system of the future right and
if you've no thing called a SMAS there
is a way to write code that javascript
is the machine language meaning that the
ASM chart says the weirdest and he talks
about this in here it's the weirdest
variation of JavaScript that you could
ever imagine but it's been carefully
constructed to run at machine speak
machine code speak and so what he talks
about is how you could imagine in
multi-threaded and multi processing
environments that we don't even use
Linux anymore what we use is we use the
JVM JavaScript virtual machine that has
the threading as the isolation and the
context switching is really cheap and we
all write in whatever language you want
then it compiles to JavaScript and it
runs really scorchingly fast I'm not
saying that that's the answer but I
can't see how JavaScript takes over as
the general-purpose scripting language
because JavaScript for one thing can't
be extended by libraries that are native
in the same way although we'll see we'll
see javascript is the and so the other
one that that sort of I couldn't I
couldn't like someone said what about
Julia and everyone says what about
skaaland I said Scala sucks it's just
it's just JavaScript done over it looks
easy because there's not as much crap in
it but it's in Scala lasts long enough
it'll be just as crufty as Java
what about elixir what about you know
whatever whatever then I can dismiss
those pretty easy because their point
or 1% and they got like 30 years to
catch up and they'll be dead like in 3
years so it just doesn't matter they're
never going to reach but it's Julie one
like I couldn't get it out of my head
and so Julia wants to be a combination
of seeing Python and it talks about
integrating libraries and Julia is kind
of common up there so so you look at a
language that truly makes life better in
terms of performance and ease of use and
something like Julia is the the kind of
dark horse in my mind that that might
sort of sneak up but I think at some
point if Julia does anything good Python
will just steal it and put it in as a C
library and then it'll be a library
called import Julia and that's a way
that that Python tends to destroy these
poor little things before they have a
chance to to grow now I got a couple
things that are kind of like crazy
Python stuff not because I'm telling you
this because I think this is the the
future but it gives you a sense of holy
crap so the first thing that I saw at
PyCon was a thing called anvil and I
happen to know about these people
because they used the same JavaScript
compiler JavaScript Python compiler I do
and all of a sudden I start these
commits going way up because this whole
thing is open source and these anvil
people so what anvil people do is they
they in effect create web applications
that are like Visual Basic and it
creates the front end and the back end
and it compiles all this Python stuff
into JavaScript and the front-end part
is Python compiled to JavaScript that
really is kind of like visual basic or
real basic where it's all these little
widgets and it's all tied together now
of course that's you know there's
performance issues etc etc etc but it's
like you know drag-and-drop programming
I liked visual basic I mean it's one of
my top five programming languages the
visual basic for at least because you
can edit visual basic for using VI but I
did I do like visual basic and I do like
drag-and-drop programming especially
because you can draw prettier things
that way but this is even crazier this
is a thing called breath on and breath
ons goal is to eliminate JavaScript from
the browser so what it does is it
compiles literally
all of Python into a SMAS and if you
watch this loads about 70 little J's
files and then what you do is you say
script text Python from browser import
document and then you just write Python
I was at a like a hack fest trying to
use this and and I would like try to
type a line and my brain just couldn't
even type the line because this is in
the background of an HTML document and
it's a script tag and it's Python and
I'm like I'm just afraid that I'll sort
of cause the world to sort of collapse
into a 1 black hole by typing the wrong
thing I'm like what is this but
literally you can write with zero
JavaScript on the page and it seems to
work pretty good I've not tried it
because I'm just afraid that I'll cross
the streams and I think you weren't
supposed to cross the streams at least
last I was told you're not supposed to
cross the streams but this is the kind
of nutty Python stuff that Python is
such a big and diverse community right
so now I'm going to tell you what I
think are the flaws in the presentation
that I just gave you to help you ask me
some questions and make some challenges
so this picture of the programmer
starting to a computer science degree -
a couple years ago the ugliness in this
the thing that makes it so I can't make
it like look how pretty it is is frickin
desktop applications and mobile
applications these desktop mobile
applications and if you look at my
career a lot of them crappy stuff that I
did in my career that was short-lived
was all because all of a sudden they
want to do something on the desktop and
it's hard it's just hard on the desktop
because you got to use the vendor
proprietary stuff and then you're kind
of just chasing the vendor proprietary
stuff and rewriting your crap all the
time like Java wanted to do it no but
you know now this poor person has to
learn Swift and Java and vb.net just so
they can write some stupid desktop
applications so I don't know how that
gets fixed and Python has historically
not done a at all a good job of desktop
applications and so that's a space that
that I would not I think it's it's
almost as likely that Python will
replace JavaScript perhaps even more
likely Python replace JavaScript and
Python
become a dominant desktop development
environment which makes me sad because I
don't think it's hard all these people
like this anvil if they would just make
a desktop environment I'm like that
would be so much more valuable than you
making a webpage that I can't optimize
but okay here's another thing the
biggest week is that weakness at this
point that Python has as a programming
language and the and the one remaining
strength that languages like Java have
is strong typing I literally would be
terrified to write a million lines I
have 1.5 million lines of code in Python
we could never release the product I
mean the day you wrote white write a 1.5
million lines of code it'll never work
I mean you if you took something the
size of Sakai now the good news is that
if you were to write Sakai in Python it
wouldn't be 1.5 million lines of code
because you don't have to make so many
things and and so you okay you make two
hundred thousand lines of code which is
still a lot of code right because the
Python is denser it's more efficient
it's easier to express an idea and
Python and Java but I'll just I'll just
point this out this is and this to me is
the this is the beginning of the end of
the java programming language actually
Oracle is the beginning of the end of
the Java programming language Gita van
Rossum the creator of Python stepped
down as the benevolent dictator for life
recently and but he hasn't left Python
what he has done is he's moved from the
being the chief do all of it the
language itself and moving into just
building one library so he - van Rossum
in his spare time is building the
library that's going to add static type
checking to Python so that tells me
something about how important he thinks
adding static type checking to Python is
so if we have the ease of use and then
the and this is done in a sort of a
separate process where it kind of goes
over the Python you kind of annotate
your Python with static checking and
then it'll look at our 250,000 lines of
code and check to see if the third
parameter was changed from string to a
dictionary by a mistake and there's a
place we use that method for hundred and
fifty places in the code and we didn't
catch them all and so it's not even
going to compile at that point and
that's what we do in Sakai right we
change the method signature and then we
find instantly all the places that we
broke within like
ten seconds and then we go fix them and
this is coming to Python and I think
that for Python truly to sort of get
above C++ and Java this kind of thing is
essential to Python so that's currently
a weakness of Python so to sort of sum
up and wrap up here we are at an
imperial conference and other than being
interesting and funny why is this
relevant in the Imperial conference and
we have folks that do Java in this
building and that's because when we
started out in 2003 we started this
project it came out of a university and
there was a bunch of smart Java people
at universities and so these smart Java
people built stuff at these universities
and like hey let's share this with each
other and then I would fly around and I
would go walk into a room in Cambridge
and I would say I'm starting this
open-source project and the people in
the room were all super senior 40 year
old Java developers with 10 years of
Java experience who were underutilized
and I'm saying come join the circus and
they're like yeah we'll join the circus
and so that was the rapid growth of
Sakai and to some degree uportal was
there's this these geniuses at
universities that were spare resources
that were like idling and bored at
universities but they were super senior
developers and for a decade we gave them
something to do that was wonderful right
and what we find is they all end up
working for Longsight they don't work at
the university anymore why because the
university just decides Java programmers
annoy us they're kind of expensive and
they want to travel and so we'll just
hire non Java programmers and not have
any programmers at all and so what
happens is today if you were to start a
Java project you would and you started
looking for volunteers for a Java
project like Sakai you would literally
find zero people under 35 that would
even go Java huh unless they were forced
to learn it in high school to get the AP
Computer Science which they refer got
one second after they finished that
class but you're not going to find the
talent that we found in Sakai just by
wandering around the world of going all
these wonderful universities and finding
three to five super talented Java
developers who were bored and like
travel right so I think from an app
aerial perspective if we want the
average age of this group to get any
smaller
we've got to stop doing everything in
Java we're not that J a cig anymore and
so I'm doing my part
I'm taking my tsuki thing with just PHP
nobody seems to like PHP very much
someone do redo in Python over the next
year and part of it is so that I can go
places and try to expose all these ideas
to young people and have them go like I
love open-source my job is boring I wish
I could do something cool in the weekend
I'm like and there's fun travel and
karaoke and it's really a blast and
you'll meet people in a career growth
etc and like and you got to learn job
and I got oh yeah man I let me get my
PlayStation back going again right no
one no one will go away from their
PlayStation long enough to learn Java
unless of course they're making a
quarter of a million dollars a year than
any age and every age will learn Java so
I think that we need not all of our
projects and and we're not going to
change Sakai to Python at least not for
five years or so guys say it out loud
I do spend time thinking about what
we'll call it right now I call it the
last LMS but okay that's that's not
that's neither here nor there I do think
that for this organization to succeed we
need things in Python I think it's that
simple if we we have the kind of values
and the kind of people in the kind of
community that young people want to be
part of and they enjoy being part of
this but they're not coming if always
say is learn Java be poor you show up
right so I think that's important to us
and I'm going to do my part I want to do
my part so I'll close with this I just
you know this is just a tweet
insane Python speed up from number JIT
JD it stands for just-in-time
something-or-other doing 27,000
simulations each of which was eight
numerical integrations using the quad I
added a decorator to my target function
and sped it up 25 times last time
eighteen point five minutes without
number seven point seven hours and I
don't even know what they're talking
about here all I know is some crazy
bunch of people made a library in Python
and made something go super fast without
making someone learn a new programming
language and so this is where like
learning Julia I just don't see it right
I don't see that julia is gonna win I
mean you could just write a gadget
that's in C and you make it a decorator
on a function and it everything goes
fast right and so without forcing people
to throw away the code that they've
actually tested and know what works you
just like drop a librarian and things go
25 times faster I mean it's amazing and
so that's the danger of Python that's
why it's a real dangerous activity to
bet against Python thank you for your
time